And now here's the quick history 14
centuries worth. Uh basically on the
death of Muhammad this is when Islam has
been consolidated on in Arabia because
he had he had his wars were against
fellow Arab tribes men who did not want
to submit. And remember the word Islam
means submit. You know it's uh basically
it's it's interesting because now it has
this sort of religious connotation the
way Christianity does. But in the early
times in Arabia it was just the Arabic
word is Islam means submit give up.
surrender to me and a Muslim is one who
has submitted and that was
it. Islam doesn't care. Muhammad didn't
care and Allah doesn't care about the
condition of your heart with God etc
etc. You have to submit to the political
authority of Muhammad and then
afterwards his successors or the
so-called khifs. At any rate he had um
once he had consolidated Arabia and he
died in 632 AD. This is when the jihad
now the the global well the the first
major wave known as the Arab conquests
blows out and starts conquering lands.
Now it's important to talk about these
lands because when you hear these
countries Egypt and Syria, North Africa,
Algeria to Morocco and so forth, many of
you, again, maybe not you because I
think you're a little more educated than
that, but most Americans just think of
those nations as always having been
Muslim. Of course, those were actually
the oldest Christian regions of the
world. And if you looked at the time in
the seventh century when when this jihad
that I'm describing happened, if you
looked at the totality of the Christian
world, of course, it was in Europe,
basically, well, not in Germany, but
southwest of the Danub brine, but the
bulk of it was in North Africa and what
we call the Middle East. Greater Syria,
which encompassed um modern day Lebanon,
Israel, Jordan, was one of the oldest,
of course, one of the oldest Christian
regions. The five ecclesiastical centers
or seas, only one was in the west, Rome.
The other four, Alexandria, Antioch,
Jerusalem, and later Constantinople,
were in the east. And long story short,
once this jihad blew up, all that
territory was swallowed up. So if you
look at a map and actual historians have
sort of quantified it, Islam in one
century conquered threearters of
Christendom permanently and it was the
more ancient, more sophisticated, more
learned center. That's why Constantine
left Rome and moved to
Constantinople. Um and it's to me it's
always mindboggling how that chapter is
just completely forgotten and ignored.
And um I've looked at textbooks, history
textbooks that talk about world history
and none of this is in there. It's
basically you hear about how Arab
culture spread in the 7th
century. There's a euphemism. Uh often
through trade. Okay, so I mean that's a
travesty if you really think about it.
Anyway, this goes on. So Muhammad dies
in 632.
One century later 732 you have Muslims
in the middle of France and this is the
famous battle of Tours Charles the
Hammer Martell where he stops them. So
now they had not only conquered all of
the older Christian regions in the
Middle East and North Africa they
conquered Spain except for a small
holdup pocket of resistance in the
northwest kind of looks like
Idaho in that Iberian Peninsula. And um
then it went into France like I said
havoc, mass havoc, etc.
slaughter uh this and um I'll get into
the actual atrocities later, but
um I'm pretty fond of giving you quotes
because uh one thing that I do in my
book, so I don't want anyone to take my
word for it, obviously. Um that's what
other historians do. So, I'm going to
give you a lot. I'm going to drown you
in quotes here. Uh but before I do, so
this war goes on now. It's 7:32 and it's
there. But then it continues century
after century and then you have these
different iterations. The Arabs start
waning and then the Turks come
originally as slave soldiers for Islam
and they're converted and then they
become the standard bearers of the
jihad. They spearheaded against uh the
rest of Europe and um this again goes
on. You have the fall of Constantinople
but even before that of course we'll get
to the Crusades but here let me give you
um let's just fast forward to the end.
This goes on now. So now in 1683, you
have 200,000 Muslims surrounding Vienna,
Austria. That's a famous battle, of
course, the siege of Vienna in
1683. And um I bring it up now because
it's actually it was recently in the
news, and I'll get to that. So, in the
battle, you probably have heard maybe of
John Soieski, the Polish king who led
history's largest cavalry charge um on
September 12th that broke the siege, the
Ottoman Turkish siege of Vienna and
basically relieved and saved Vienna. Um,
I bring that up anyway because only
recently
uh Poland created a statue of Soies um
commemorating this event, the the rescue
of um Vienna. And Vienna had originally
agreed to put it up somewhere on the
hill that he and his army had come down
to save Vienna, Kalen Hill, I think. I
forget the name, but and um all of a
sudden the city council of Vienna
started making complaints saying, "Oh,
it's not the right size or we need this
or we need that." and Poland spent like
10 years making changes and then it
finally came out and they said, "Look,
we're just not going to do it." Why?
Islamophobia. So now, so, so the the
statue was actually sent back and now
it's in KKO, I believe. And it's kind of
ironic that basically you have these
people in Vienna, they're willing to
spit in the eye of the people or at
least the descendants of those who saved
them in order to appease the descendants
of those who are persecuting them. And
if you actually look at Vienna, and we
can maybe discuss that real quick. It's
become a hotbed of Islamic
radicalization like other European um
cities. At any rate, going back to the
history, let me give you a couple of
quotes. So, here's Franco Cardi and um
he wrote the following in his book,
Islam and Europe. Um he's a a French, I
believe, um or Italian historian, well
known. He writes, quote, "If we ask
ourselves how and when the modern notion
of Europe and the European identity was
born, we realize the extent to which
Islam was a factor, albeit a negative
one, in its creation. Repeated Muslim
aggression against Europe between the
7th to 8th centuries, then between the
14th and the 18th centuries was a
violent midwife to Europe." And this is
actually very accurate. uh the the
concept of Europe itself and how Europe
came to be was in large measure created
in response to a lot of violent pressure
from Islam. Um I already mentioned to
you how large original Christendom was.
And so there's a reason when you look um
around Europe it's surrounded by Muslims
right south of the Mediterranean Muslim
lands east Russia east of Russia you
actually have the the the Stan lands the
Mongol lands that also became Islamic
the Golden Horde. And so basically all
of those were formerly Christian. They
became Islamic through conquest and it
kept just going in and in deeper into
Europe. Spain, like I said, the Balkans
had all been conquered. Uh, a lot of
people know of Constantinople, but
obviously there was a lot more to it
than that. Hungary, Romania,
Greece. Um, here's now another good
quote from Bernard Lewis, well-known
historian, deceased now, of course. He
writes, quote, "We tend nowadays to
forget that for approximately a thousand
years from the advent of Islam in the
7th century until the second siege of
Vienna in 1683, which I just mentioned,
Christian Europe was under constant
threat from Islam. The double threat of
conquest and conversion. Most of the new
the new domains were rested from
Christendom. Syria, Palestine, Egypt,
and North Africa were all Christian
countries, no less indeed rather more
than Europe. All this left a deep sense
of loss and a deep terror. Okay, very
accurate. It's very It's very hard
nowadays to come across such frankness
in historical books that deal with this
topic, except mine, of course.
It's also worth mentioning that in the
modern histories that people write and I
I might try to get into the sort of
semantic games that historians play to
sort of whitewash all this but you know
the these violent midwives of Europe are
almost always now to today known as
Arabs, Sarissens, Moors, Turks,
Ottomans, Tatars. They're always given a
national name. Okay. Um but the reality
is if you dig into the sources, they saw
themselves first and foremost as Muslims
and what they were doing was um
fulfilling the Islamic mandate via
jihad. That's what comes out in their
sources. This wasn't just one of the
games that historians try to play is
like, okay, it's one national group
attacking another. Turks attacking
Greeks, okay, no big deal. But like I
said, if you look into it every time,
the rationale of these various groups,
whoever they may may be, is the ISIS
rationale, the Islamic State rationale,
the one that you've been told has
nothing to do with Islam. That was the
rationale for 14 centuries worth of
jihad that completely terrorized much of
the world, especially the Christian
world. So, one of the topics, for
example, is slavery. I mentioned this, I
think, to someone the other day, but
here in America or in the west, you
mention the word slavery. means white
sla whites enslaving blacks. That's a
that's it. And it's kind of like amazing
because the reality is yeah that did
happen. And this is again this is this
is one of the problems. It's not that
these historians or the fake histories
that I'm discussing are lying. They just
they always present things in a vacuum
without telling you. So of course in
reality everyone enslaved everyone and
Muslims especially enslaved a lot of
Europeans. Based on a tally I did a
while back, 14 million Europeans were
enslaved by Muslims from as far as
Iceland, from Iceland to Russia. Okay?
And this is mostly from the very
beginning from that those centuries that
I was mentioning in the seventh and 8th,
but especially in the 15th and 16th
century and the 17th century, you may
have heard of the Barbar pirates in
North Africa. They subsisted entirely on
enslaving Europeans. And I think in just
um a few c a few decades in the 16th
century there was as many as 1.25
million European slaves in the markets
of
alers but we don't hear about that do
we? Um so speaking of barbar and trying
to really to cap off this whole long
epic jihad that went on century after
century. Few people know that even that
no one was spared. Not even America.
America's very first war as a nation um
after independence was with Muslims who
were acting on the very same impetus
that I'm describing to you right now.
And I'm talking of course of the Barbary
Wars. And uh so basically what happened
is these North African Muslim vessels
started attacking American vessels in
the Atlantic and enslaving their
soldiers and really mistreating them.
You can see it in the sources. Um, and
what's interesting is Thomas Jefferson
and I think John Adams met with one of
the ambassadors from
Barbarie and Jefferson then wrote a
letter back to Congress. Uh, he met the
they met the ambassador to try to parlay
and get the get the American sailors
back. So Jefferson wrote the following
in a letter from 1786 to Congress.
quote, "We took the liberty to make some
inquiries concerning the grounds of
their the Barbrey pirates pretensions to
make war upon nations who had done them
no injury, such as America, and observed
that we Americans considered all mankind
as our friends, who had done us no
wrong, nor had given us any provocation.
The ambassador from Barbarie answered us
that it was founded on the laws of their
prophet, that it was written in their
Quran, that all nations who should not
have acknowledged their authority were
sinners, that it was their right and
duty to make war upon them wherever they
could be found, and to make slaves of
all they could take as prisoners, and
that every Muslimman or Muslim who
should be slain in battle was sure to go
to paradise. You can only imagine what
this enlightened thinker was thinking
when he was told all this. But as you
can see, I I give you that quote because
that is the rationale and the logic that
Muslims had used in all those centuries
before that I was discussing from the
7th century here. Here here we here we
come up until 1800 19th century and it's
the same logic and it's the logic that
we've been forever told has nothing to
do with Islam and is just a
representation of a few hand handful of
radicals al-Qaeda, ISIS, etc., etc.
Um, and the thing is every this was so
well known what I'm describing right
now, which again maybe not so much to
you, but to most people in this country
is just bizarre and they've never heard
of it. This was so well known up until
recently. So consider this quote from
none other than Theodore Teddy Roosevelt
who was no mean historian himself. In
his book, his 1916 book uh fear God and
take your part. He wrote the following.
Christianity was saved in Europe solely
because the peoples of Europe fought. If
the peoples of Europe in the seventh and
8th centuries and on up to and including
the 17th century had not possessed a
military equality with and gradually a
growing superiority over the Muhammadans
who invaded Europe, Europe would at this
moment be Muhammadan and the Christian
religion would be exterminated. Wherever
the Muhammadans have had complete sway,
wherever the Christians have been un
unable to resist them by the sword,
Christianity has ultimately disappeared.
From the hammer of Charles Martell to
the sword of Soies, Christianity owed
its safety in Europe to the fact that it
was able to show that it could and would
fight as well as the Muhammadan
aggressor. Which brings us to the
Crusades, of course, which ironically to
me, um, as important as they are, they
were really a drop in the bucket of the
totality of warfare between Christians
and Muslims, but they're the ones that
you heard of because they make
Christians look bad because in the
Crusades, you have Christians moving
from their homeland into what's
perceived as Muslim territory. So,
they're the aggressors. So, we can talk
about that. But if you look at the all
the wars, I describe them a lot in my
book, Sword and Scimitar. Again, that's
just a drop in the bucket because most
of the attacks and the assaults were
from the Muslims on Christian lands. And
even the crusades were actually part of
just war. Recall that all those
territories I told you about, including
the Holy Land, Jerusalem, and Egypt were
Christian before Muslims took it. First,
the first crusaders were aware of this.
Um, so when they were going there, in
their mind, they were liberating ancient
Christian territories and bringing them
back under Christian rule, which again
fits into just war theory. But so what
actually provoked the first crusade
again was the it was another a new wave
of Islamic jihad and terror was taking
place especially after the year
1071 after the pivotal battle of
Manzakert um in Asia Minor close to
Armenia
um after the Turks won that basically
Anatolia or Asia Minor or what we now
call Turkey one of the most ancient
Christian terri regions it's where St.
Paul wrote many of his epistles to was
overrun by Turks and they just engaged
in all sorts of atrocities and
slaughters and according to the
contemporary sources tens if not
hundreds of thousands of Christians
mostly Greeks and Armenians were
butchered and slaughtered and the rest
taken um into slavery and um again and
the churches were desecrated ritually
and burned and torched and turned into
mosques um just in one city alone anie
1,000 churches were torched to the
ground that's just and Again, um this
what I'm describing to you is right
before the first crusades, but all of
these types of atrocities were what were
occurring from the very start during the
initial conquests that began in the 7th
century. I mean, have you ever heard for
example of the mad khalif
Hakimah in the year 1009 or 1009 he
actually according to Muslim sources I'm
thinking of the Arab historian al- Makzi
destroyed 30,000 churches in one year in
greater Syria and Egypt. So again that
underscores how Christian that region
was already into the 11th century and
the sorts of persecution that Muslims
were putting them through. So anyway,
fast forward again to what I was telling
you. 1071, Asia Minor is now being
overrun and killed. And now here's a
quote from Emperor Alexius the first. He
was the um Eastern Roman or as they call
it, Byzantine Emperor. And he summarized
what was happening to Asia Minor and to
Christians in a letter to um his friend
Count Robert of Flanders who had
actually become one of the first leaders
of the first crusade. So here's a quote.
The holy places are desecrated and
destroyed in countless ways. Noble
mothers and their daughters robbed of
everything are violated one after
another like animals. Some of their
rapists shamelessly place virgins in
front of their own mothers and force
them to sing wicked and obscene songs
until they have finished having their
ways with them. Men of every age and
description, boys, youths, old men,
nobles, peasants, and what is worse
still and yet more distressing, clerks
and monks, and woe of woes.
Even bishops are forcibly defiled with
the sin of sodomy. So they were raping
the holy men and the monks and so forth.
So after the passage of these five
centuries of peaceful coexistence, we
finally come to to the council of
Claremont in 1095 where Pope Urban II
called for the first crusade. He too
knew what was going on. And here's a
quote of what he said. They, the
Muslims, have completely destroyed some
of God's churches and have converted
others to the use of their own cult,
meaning mosques. They ruined the altars
with filth and defilement. They
circumcised Christians and smear the
blood from the circumcision of the
altars and throw it into the baptismal
fonts. They are pleased to kill others
by cutting open their bellies,
extracting the end of their intestines,
and tying it to a stake. Then with
flogging they drive their victims around
the stake until when their viscera have
spilled out they fall dead on the
ground. They tie others again to stakes
and shoot arrows at them. They seize
others stretch out their necks and try
to see whether they can cut off their
heads with a single blow of a naked
sword. And what shall I say about the
shocking grape of women? Who is to
repair this damage if you do not do it?
Rise up and remember the manly deeds of
your ancestors. And it is at that point
that the famous phrase deos vult came
where they all got up and said god wills
it. So such are the heroic and noble
origins of the first crusade. Uh so that
is the dangers of fake history and we're
living it right now because you don't
appreciate what really happened. And
I'll leave you the final and very
precient quote by uh Hillary Bellac, a
European u I think Anglo French
historian I think a friend or
contemporary of Chesterton um who lived
between 1870 and 1953. In his book the
great heresies which I think he wrote in
1938. 1938. Keep in mind this is about a
century ago or I mean almost a century
ago. He writes quote millions of modern
people of the white civilization that is
the civilization of Europe and America
have forgotten all about Islam. They
have never come in contact with it. They
take for granted that it is decaying and
that anyway it's just a foreign religion
which will not concern them. It is as a
fact the most formidable and persistent
enemy which our civilization has had and
may at any moment become as large a
menace in the future as it has been in
the past. The whole spiritual strength
of Islam is still present in the masses
of Syria and Anatolia of the East Asian
mountains of Arabia, Egypt and North
Africa. The final fruit of this
tenacity, the second period of Islamic
power may be delayed, but I doubt
whether it can be permanently postponed.
And I think that's where we're at right
now.